i remember not wanting to die screaming
and yelling and
begging and pee in my pants i said dear
heavenly father just let me die with
dignity i'll say your name
every day and i will do whatever i can
for my fellow inmate
and i said inmate i never thought i was
getting out of jail and by the grace of
god he said okay
i'm gonna give you a chance here
danny bloody trejo in the building how
are you doing man
great thank you pleasure to have you
here are you
the most killed actor in hollywood
history
yeah they've got me yeah i wasn't
the last time i counted i was 68 i think
i'm about 90 now but it's kind of ironic
right because you've been killed
on screen a lot but somehow managed to
make it out of your life
so far alive that's what everybody says
they didn't i remember when the pandemic
everyone was scared of
not the pandemic everybody's scared of
the millennium
oh the millennium 2000 the millennium
the millennium
and they asked me what do you think
about the millennium i should
i wouldn't do that i wasn't supposed to
get out of the 60s i don't
i've been on god's time since 1968.
borrowed time man yeah this is extra
time
it's weird right because most people's
impression of what like a tough guy
or a hard lad or a guy from the streets
is
it comes from movies you know not
everybody gets to see
those people in the flesh but then most
of the people that play those roles
aren't from the streets so it's
different for you because you've sort of
earned your stripes you are
and then you get to display it as well
right you know it's really funny
what you just said when i was trying to
write my book
i i kept getting people that were like
english literature majors they just
it they would change a few words and it
didn't sound like me it sounded like a
like a like an english lesson and so so
uh uh
donald logue who is a friend of mine
we've been
friends since 1991 and uh
uh he was he was
raised in calexico uh uh right by the
mexican border
okay his his his
his town crosses the mexican border you
know and so
so uh uh uh
it was like when we started talking as
friends he not only knew that he was
like
an english literature major but he knew
the streets
in fact his hometown had nothing but
alleys
so so it was like we understood each
other and
we started writing it and it just flowed
i gave it to my
uh kid's mom
i read this and she just it sounds like
i'm talking to you and that's okay cool
then that's what we wanted yeah
what was the process like writing that
about two year
half years just we would sit together
out in my backyard or
or driving around or just wherever we
stay
kind of like hung real close for about
two and a half years almost three years
and
put it together that's awesome man i had
uh mark manson on who's an author that's
just written will smith's memoir
slash biography autobiography so him and
will smith have worked together for the
last
three years and he said exactly the same
thing just live together it wasn't
go into a room for 13 hours talking to a
tape recorder and then someone leaves
it's this long very emergent process
yeah
i would sometimes we would like we would
like wake up
you know he'd be on one couch i'd be on
the other we
fell asleep you know i mean it was just
and it was amazing because
you know he's got two boys i got two
boys i got i got uh my daughter she's
you know they're all grown now so we
were able to
able to kind of hang so rolling it back
right to your childhood you had this
uncle that really shaped your childhood
right like what lessons did you learn
from him
everything learned i learned what i
thought was
how to be a man and it was but it only
was it only
was a good deal in san quentin
you know it was only a uh you know i
learned
i learned how to survive in a
in an unsurvivable world you know it's
like
san quentin is kind of the
the epitome of of you're not going to
come out
you know and if you do
you you were either a predator or you
were prey
yeah a lot of pray didn't come out so
what were some of the lessons what did
he what were the tactics and the tools
that he gave you to make sure that you
weren't proud
don't don't ever fight down you know
don't ever be a bully
don't take a step backwards
ever you know i mean just never it
doesn't matter
it you know it is it's saying
prison it's kind of like there are no
tough guys
people think they're these tough guys
they're no such thing as a
tough guy in prison because first of all
uh four inches of steel will take care
of a tough guy in a minute
you know now i am not gonna if i sock
uh somebody they're gonna suck me back
and then we're gonna fight and then
we're gonna roll around and then we're
gonna get shot
okay we're gonna get caught so if
if i have a resentment or an angry or
somebody disrespected me
and i come up behind them and
stab them three times and walk away i
didn't get caught and i won
you know i won and that that
enhanced my reputation
and now audi well that was a cowardly
act
yeah but i'm still alive you tell this
story
i think it was after you moved to a
school and somebody
started up against you and then there
was a big group of their friends outside
and
you mentioned something like you were
prepared to go to a level of violence
that
they weren't at all yeah they didn't
know
the the average the average person on
the street doesn't know
the level of violence that is in san
quentin it's
ridiculous i find out i'll fight you let
me
find something i can beat you over the
head with and people don't understand
that the bottom line to an argument
is a murder you know the bottom line i'm
not
you know i i've watched people argue a
little bit
but basically i have never seen
anybody killed except for in prison
that didn't start with an argument
you know in prison i always say it's the
most right now place in the world
because you can die
because somebody that you didn't even
know
didn't get a letter or
got a letter you understand you know
it's like bad or whatever and it's like
all of a sudden somebody comes running
down
bang bang bang and it stabs you it'll
you know
how'd that happen you know and so
so it's like uh i don't i don't fight i
don't argue i don't
i don't argue would be one because i
know it's like wait a minute man i don't
i don't want i don't know if he knows
that the bottom line to an argument is a
murder i don't know how bad he wants to
win this argument
so so see because in prison
if we argue and
you win then i walk away thinking wow
that guy made me look like a punk i mean
he really did that
i'm really a punk everybody thinks i'm a
punk
uh-oh i might get raped watch out
let me fix this so
that's so that's what you're taught so
it's like
wait a minute it doesn't happen the cost
of
losing an argument and both people still
being alive is too great to rep
the reputation of the one that lost
exactly wow that was good
that's a good i'm gonna i'm gonna write
that down and i'm not to give you credit
for it that's fine that's absolutely
fine
wasn't there a story about how
a mexican gang rivalry started over a
pair of shoes
yeah that's the next mafia shoe wars
it was uh uh pie face this this uh
mexican mafia member gave a pair of
shoes
that he stole uh
from somebody from a different area
like there was north and south there's
there's southern
mexicans and there's northern mexicans
southern mexicans
are are uh uh mexican mafia
liame the the
northern mexicans are la familia nuestra
they're another so pie face stole a pair
of shoes
from one of the nortenos one of the guys
from
and he gave it to robot solace who
was one of the leaders of the mexican
mafia
he gave them and so when the guy from
the
northern saw hey those are my shoes
and um robot
ended up saying yeah we'll take them
then and so
a robot ended up going into this
stabbing both
him and his cell partner so that's how
that started
per pair of shoes that were their shoes
so what were the what was one of the
biggest robberies that you were a part
of
when you were younger oh
god man i would say uh circle liquor was
pretty good and then uh dale's market
i think dale's market was a pretty big
market in the neighborhood and we took
that down and
it was uh got away with it how did that
come about
just we needed money you know you know
that was
it was funny it's like this was this
therapist or this
girl that knew about therapy we were
talking i said danny you have a robbery
mentality
what are you talking about you always
think there's money coming
robbers i need money i'll go get
something
so life is not an atm meme yeah
life is not an atm machine but i suppose
it is when you can go and pick it off
the streets as a young guy if you need
money then
there's a corner shop there's a corner
shop there's a man on the street there's
a whatever
exactly you know until somebody shoots
you and you got to remember that
that especially nowadays i feel sorry
for people that are committing crimes
now
because everybody got guns there was a
time
in america when you know only the bad
guys and the cops have gotten
no the shopkeeper's got one and his
daughter's got one and
no grandma grandma's got an automatic
yeah nine millimeters so you better cool
it you know
and but you know good bad it's terrible
because we keep having these
you know these uh mass shootings you
know and
and i'm sorry but but i'm one of the
people that say
automatic weapons are only good for
killing people
that's it you don't know i'm not against
foreign
automatic weapons the only thing they're
good for is killing people you can't
shoot
rabbits with them
didn't you end up robbing antonio
banderas by accident
everybody says that i never robbed after
uh
who's who's trying to stitch you up with
the story of antonio
are they trying to start a mexican
spanish war here or something like that
no but but uh uh cheech marin
went to a school called alemany i went
to a school called san fernando
we used to take money away from the kids
from alameda
nice christian catholic school you know
i mean but but uh
but i never robbed jesus i love cheese
that's funny so how come if the mexican
mafia is floating around how come you
never joined it
my uncle gilbert bless his soul
that don't get into any any
prison gang he said once you get into a
prison gang
you have dedicated your life to being
incarcerated you know
not just to the gang but the state of
california yeah that's it yeah
and uh most
ah it's unbelievable and so i i just
never
you know they they it's great
i knew them all i mean you know edward
james oh my saved edward james almost
because i knew some guys you know and uh
he won't admit it though you know i mean
but but uh
but uh it's uh it's you know it's like
you know i told him when he was gonna
make that movie
don't you know come on me and eddie
bunker the guy that got me into the
movies right
because eddie knew joe morgan they were
best friends
joe morgan ran the mexican mafia and so
so eddie bunker uh
and i talked to edward james when he had
asked me to be in
the movie american me and and uh
we asked him did you talk to joe and he
goes oh yeah yeah yeah
and it was a lie he didn't you know and
he kept saying that
that he made this movie very theatrical
and i said joe eddie you're not dealing
with theatrical people here
you know and uh you know you're dealing
with guys that
wake you up in the middle of the night
and slit your throat
and he was saying no but you know blue
he wouldn't listen
so he got in big trouble
in fact he got so much if if after
american me you don't
you didn't see edward james until they
gave him this break on uh
on the mayans and it's funny any film
that edward james is on won't call me on
it because
you know he kind of is still
you know as i understand you know it's
like he's scared of me
i think it's funny
all right so you get through the youth
system and then you end up in
big boy prison after a bit of time what
was the
big boy prison yeah exactly you're out
of the kindergarten you're into the
proper school now
what was the toughest prison wing that
you ended up in eventually
well you you talk about solidad quentin
folsom tracy they're all
they're all tough prisons
and uh uh uh b-section in prison it's
like you're just locked up
and and uh i used to they used to let me
out the yard of b-section it was funny
because
because uh uh the guards would always
tease me
and and i there's two baseball mitts
and and there's a baseball right and the
guard hey treyo who are you gonna bring
who are you gonna
play catch with you because
i know about that by myself your mother
[Laughter]
yeah why do you why do you like to play
catch with this bullet
little bastard they would you know we'd
like bathroom
it was just you know but i'll never
forget
san quentin b section you're right on
the bay
you're right on the bay and so there's a
two a chain-link fence
and another chain-link fence down there
and it's the gun towers
you're not gonna get out of there
they're gonna shoot you but it's
probably the best view
in the prison you know and
but you're by yourself but i say sit
there and there was this song
that came out it was sitting
on the dock in the bay wasting time
and i sit there like oh my god i wonder
if he wrote that
did you write that for me god you know i
mean i mean
and i use it it was just a and uh
and it was funny the guard knew that
that song he would play it
and they would uh be and he'd go hey hey
was that for you trail
here i'd give him the finger
but but uh uh i think that's the only
time i felt any kind of uh
oh why am i here you know what i mean
otherwise i'd be into it you don't think
of anything else but
but with a beautiful view
but especially when you've been in the
system for a long time right when that's
when your friends are there your
community is there your culture is there
everything you know what i went to
juvenile hall there was so many
mexicans in juvenile hall when i went i
thought
mexicans were supposed to go did i write
a passage or something you know because
it was all
it was mexican-american african-american
and
poor whites no no rich white they knew
you know they were rich why didn't you
want to you know but
and and most of the white guys in
juvenile hall
kind of gravitate towards the mexicans
because there's not enough of them to
stand alone
now there is because there's so many
poor white guys it's not like
we're even now
you know the world the world made us all
poor yeah
so you met charles manson in prison
didn't you what was that story he tells
us
in the county jail but let me tell
charlie wasn't the guy
that you saw on the tv specials
all right he was a ah
god he was like five foot four or five
foot five
a little scrawny he was
poor kind of like a bum really he he had
a
he had a uh a string
for a belt he tied his pants with a
string
because he could afford a belt you know
and and everybody else we dressed
you know cool ironed our pen and uh
and so the some of the prisoners were
gonna take advantage of them because
they're taking
advantage of anybody that's small and we
found out that he could hypnotize you
so we we let him sleep in front of our
cell
to to you know to make sure that
nobody had hurt him and and uh he got us
loaded on weed
and and three other guys in this cell
everybody else had like
six guys in their show we only had three
because
we were special
i had two killers with me so so
so uh and then uh
and then he got us loaded on weed and i
said well get us loaded on heroin
so the three of us tried to get loaded
he got two of us loaded on heroin
one guy just woke up and afterwards i
asked him how come welcome he couldn't
do him and he said
he asked did you ever get loaded on
heroin no well your mind doesn't know
how to work
you understand your mind doesn't know
how to react
so if i tell you to do something
while you're hypnotized and you haven't
done it before or you don't know how to
do it
uh you'll just wake up
and that's what kept happening yeah so
you're saying that he got he got you
guys loaded up on heroin weed but there
was no heroin or weed in
the room right he was doing this purely
through hypnosis people know when i get
loaded on heroin my eyes
i get red under my eyes and that's like
literally
uh the first thing you blah you you
throw up you dump and i mean uh
me and chat that was like it's like we
both got
he dumped in the sink i dumped in the in
the toilet
and looked like hey but you know
and oh everybody was like shocked and
and this uh uh uh
johnny ronnie cruz he was like well what
happened you
you he never got loaded and
and uh ball i kept i you know
i was sorry when they transferred
charlie out
you've basically got unlimited access to
anything that you want because he can
just keep on hypnotizing you back into
it
what was he in for do you know why he
was there i have no idea i have no idea
yeah he was nothing nothing of any
you know cause he was a petty thief he
was he wasn't
you know not to speak ill of the dead
but charlie couldn't have done that
any place anytime but right there and my
friend george perry
knew him in frisco knew him in oakland
okay and he was a
he was a uh a scrawny little
hippie and the girls that he
got linda kasey all of them were broken
you know they were up in oakland and san
francisco
being ripped off by the pimps and and
raped by the pimps and
and so
he came around with a big bus and some
acid and said
let me lead you so it was kind of like
they looked at him like
yeah he's the messiah you know they were
already vulnerable they were already
primed for somebody like him to come in
and say
they were so broken you know so needed
needed somebody to take care of them
in the same way that you could have done
with a bit of extra heroin or weed in in
prison
absolutely all right so you ended up um
you ended up looking at the death
penalty at one point what's the story
behind that
we we uh it was cinco de mayo in 1968
and cinco de mayo to a mexican
a real mexican spell backwards is
get bail money because you know
you're gonna do something stupid you
know you tequila yeah
and uh and so there was like you
you had two thousand drunk mexicans in
cinco de mayo and
a riot when when a riot starts rape by
chuckles sucked a free person
death penalty uh um
when a riot starts it is like an
explosion
everybody any resentment you have you
start taking care of it any
you just start you hate prisons so you
start breaking glass
so there's a huge explosion of violence
henry kicked the coach
strawman
it was alleged that i threw a rock and
hit lieutenant gibbons
and but there's no proof he's like you
somebody said that
and uh but all three gas chamber
offenses so
when we went to the hole they took out
of 2 000 inmates they took three of us
to the hole
and uh we're sitting there and i
remember henry yelling
hey danny they're gonna top us up
yeah i think so and and i remembered
all this all my life grammar school
middle school high school potential
danny has a lot of potential but he
can't sit still
danny has a lot of potential but he
won't stop talking danny has a lot of
potential
but he won't stop doing burglaries i'm
all just
i had all this potential and uh
and i remember sitting in a cell naked
because you're naked and i'm i'm
i'm looking somebody got got uh
[ __ ] and scraped it on the wall and said
god sucks
and i remember okay god you know what
happened to all that potential
i remember thinking about where'd my
potential go
and i remember not wanting to die
screaming and yelling and and begging
and and pee in my pants i said dear
heavenly father just let me die with
dignity
i'll say your name every day and i will
do whatever i can for my fellow inmate
and i said inmate i never thought i was
getting out of jail
and uh and by the grace of god he said
okay
punk i'm gonna give you a chance here
d.a reject rejected it okay get this out
of here
you guys deal with it so they topped us
and now
august 23rd 1969 i'll never forget
the month before uh the the
the parole agent that was on the board
mad dog madden that was his real name
matt doug madden said trey we're going
to give you
a chance to spread your wings you've
been good for 11 months
you haven't gone for 11 days without
some kind of beef so
uh get out of here
and bring us back a life sentence
because i only had a 10-year talk
but i'll never forget that bring us back
a life sentence
so we won't have to bother with you
anymore and
and like 30 days later august 23rd i i
walked out of prison
and i was shocked
and but i kept remembering you know that
all right i didn't i didn't make a deal
with god to
get me a good job or not to let me get
caught sneaking into my house because i
was late or
you know i said let me die with dignity
you know so you know i might do that and
i asked him a couple of months ago how
am i doing god he said
you're almost out of hell trail keep it
up you know so borrowed time man
borrowed time ever since i told you i
told you it's like it's it
you know what i mean it's like but take
me now my kids are great
i got great insurance they'll be all
right you know i mean it's like uh
uh everything good that has ever
happened to me has happened as a direct
result
of helping someone else so you know i
what
oh i got it you know i'm cool you know i
just i'll keep helping
have you ever watched peaky blinders the
series
no okay so it's a british series really
huge some massive actors in it tom
hardy's in it some of the huge guys
and um it's just after world war one and
in it these guys have gone off and
they've been in the battle of the somme
right in world war one and then all of
them are sure that they're gonna die
they get trapped in a tunnel and they're
fighting the the germans
hand to hand and they're all certain
they're gonna die and they make a deal
with each other down
in one of the tunnels that's collapsed
and they say
if we get out of this everything after
that is extra
yeah and that's exactly the same as the
situation that you had
hey i wasn't supposed to get out of the
60s by the grace of god and it's funny
you know when i had brain surgery that
this uh
this uh doctor he said i've never taken
more blood out of somebody's head
because i i was uh i was bleeding from
two blood vessels in uh my daughter
she's a comedian she well doctor he has
a lot of room up there
[Laughter]
and then and then the doctor said he
said he said
you know people have your injury go home
go to sleep and die you flew around the
world you know
and uh and and
my daughter said it again well god's not
through with him yet and
it's kind of stuck and i thank you jesus
says
you know i'll be i'm okay when you're
through i beat cancer
i beat hepatitis c i beat brain surgery
you know and so
you don't think i'm glad he's not
through with me i i'll still keep doing
his work
i love it man so you also beat
a long star a bunch of long-standing
addictions right alcoholism other sorts
of drugs hard drugs heroin weed and
stuff like that
all in solitary in the same period i've
been clean
now for it'll be 53 years in august
and uh and my life would not be the same
if i hadn't you know i'd still be in
drugs or in like she'll be in prison but
most people can't just get past that
sort of a dependency on faith alone like
just the fact that you've got
you know you've made a deal with someone
there's all of these habits it's a
physiological dependency there's a
psychological dependency there's a
cultural
impetus to come and do it how how did
you break that
i've been going to 12-step programs
since 1968. the first time i ever
walked into a 12-step program was in got
1959
it was by accident i thought it was a
party and uh and literally
uh but i learned what it was
you understand and now it's like i still
i went to a meeting last night
because we're just getting out of this
pandemic [ __ ]
and and now it's like wow we go to
meetings you know and
and so i've seen some of the friends
that i've gotten
it was like it's amazing feeling to be
back in the fold you know and so
i could have done it alone no way and i
feel sorry
for anybody that does though and people
that try to do it alone
you should see them yeah i'm sober so
what
okay i'm clear guys they're angry no
it's like i can't afford that
you know and uh resentment resentment
is like me taking poison hoping you die
it's absolutely no good whatsoever
a resentment only hurts me so what i
have to do i have to write about
resentments
and and get them out and say hey you
know what i'm sorry
i resented you because i thought you
looked at my wife kind of
disrespectfully or whatever
and you hey no way i wasn't looking at
your wife i was looking at it look at
that babe behind her you know
and then you know so there's always a
you know
people do things for themselves not
not to me you you understand you know
i mean if somebody does something to me
then
hey wait you don't do that you
understand there's a problem
but nine times out of ten they weren't
even thinking about me
it's weird that you can have someone who
breaks their
drug addiction perhaps on their own you
know just sheer force of will or
whatever it might be
but the price that they have to pay for
that because they haven't done it in the
program where they have a accountability
and they have friends and socialize it
out of them and
let go and all that stuff you can be
free from the drugs but not free from
the thing that caused you to want the
drugs in the first place
exactly the last that's why the program
that's what the program helps you with
that's what the therapy helps you with
is the things that
started you on drugs the things that
because a lot of people get started on
drugs
and they just stop because maybe they
don't have the same monsters inside
that a drug addict has or or a pill head
has
you know this i remember timmy sanchez
tim sanchez my next-door neighbor my
grandmother's
i smoked weed you know i mean and then i
tried to carry timmy i turned timmy onto
we were like
nine and and he he got sick he never
smoked weed again yeah i don't like it
and yet me i was i'd smoke weed here
you know i used just steal my uncle's
weed mikey give me some coffee
i would still i would steal my uncle's
weed you know
and uh and i loved it and then
and then later on you know it's like you
just graduate
all right so you're out of jail now and
then you become a counselor you start
working helping people
and then that actually leads you somehow
into getting into the movie business
yeah one of the guys that i was working
with helping stay clean
was uh an extra he was like working as
an extra and he got me into working as
an extra cause
you got 50 bucks cash they used to pay
you 50 bucks and then over time you you
god you know i'm gonna make about 80
bucks in a night you know
so so uh uh it was cat don't tell the
irs
there's cash right
they'll come back in 1965 you made this
much but uh
but uh uh i uh
i was i was trying to do this and then
one night he calls me and says hey dan
i'm down here and
doing this film there's a lot of blow
down here man i'm i'm kind of worried i
might use
and so i went down to hang out with him
i was on that movie anyway and so
i went down there what i do i run into a
guy named eddie bunker
and i'm looking at him and i think i
know you hey you're danny trevor
i saw you in the lightweight in the
welterweight title up in quinn
i said you're eddie bunker what's up
betty
my uncle bought a robbery from eddie
bunker in 1962 i think
right and uh and so i started talking
and
and he goes yeah what do you i i what
are you doing here eddie he says
i wrote the i adapted the screenplay
and then he asked me what i was doing
and i said [ __ ] they're giving me 50
bucks for
acting like a convict and uh we laugh
because we've both been being a convict
for free forever right
you know and uh he says uh
are you still boxing no no i train man i
don't get in the face anymore i'm
40 years old do you think i want to mess
this up anymore
he says he says uh hey
we need somebody to train one of the
actors out of box
and i said what's it pay cuz i'm making
50 bucks a day and he says
320 a day and eddie how bad you want
this guy beat up
you know i thought come on 320 bucks
she gotta done it for another 50. and uh
and he says uh
no no wait danny this actor is really
high strung he might
suck you hey for 320 bucks
give him a stick homie i've been beat up
for free and
i start training an actor named eric
roberts
how to box for the movie runaway train
john voight eric roberts brilliant movie
got nominated for academy award both
eric and john got nominated
for best actor and best supporting actor
brilliant movie andre kochalowski the
director
one of the best directors ever
and uh and literally uh um
i uh i started training eric
andre saw that i could handle eric
now the the guy that they had
cast to fight eric in this movie
was uh almost as pretty as eric
and and i mean basically eric is
prettier than his sister and so like two
pretty guys up against each other yeah
yeah
guys against each other wait this ain't
gonna work you know what i mean
and it looks silly i mean
what is this like the battle of the
queens or something you just
done and uh and then eric want to wear
these tight shorts
and you don't wear tight shorts in
prison and
but no no i want to wear the occasion so
andre i remember andre kozlowski kept
going
contrast he was a russian aristocrat
contrast
contrast and he would go to air go oh
and then you go to this other guy go oh
and then you go to me go you go
[Laughter]
eddie eddie is he making fun of me shut
up man
just shut up and uh so i'm waiting there
and he goes
so uh eric says okay well then i'll
fight him he picks me right so
so andre saw that eric could do whatever
i told him to do
you know and uh and he
because he you know eric's a movie star
and
movie stars can do whatever they wanted
dicks
and so so so you know sometimes they
don't feel like working so they'll just
no no i don't know right now
i know everybody be waiting and and
because he's in his trailers
so um andre saw that if i told him come
on let's go he'd go again so
andre comes up to me
danny you be in movie
and you fight eric in moving
and you be my friend
now if you cover a prison background
a little suspicious when somebody says
you be my friend
and you want to say look punk i'm going
to shower with you you know what i mean
so
so so i told eddie eddie now listen
i'm going to train the kid for 320
because because then
andre leans over and he kisses me on one
cheek kisses me on the otg
walks away i said yeah i'll train the
kid but
if i'm going to be kissing that old man
i want more money
but he says no no he's european he's
european
they all do it you know what i mean
so but let me tell you when i found out
what that old man did with me
for me give me a a psycho [ __ ]
he could kiss me in the mouth oh andre
i love you that's where i got my sad
card that's
that's right all of a sudden people
everybody on set i went from hey you
to mr trevor would you like some coffee
like
yeah two cups and sugar and cream
and give me one of those pilates that
cookies you know what i mean
and uh anything is wow that's when eddie
told me
listen the whole world can think you're
a movie star but you can't
and i said why and and he showed me
we walked up to a movie star and we
listened to him
we listen to the people around him oh oh
we love you
we love you you got some pretty nose oh
look at your eyes
and then he walked away i hate that punk
god i'd like to kill that son i'm a
[ __ ]
he's entitled something yeah and i said
wow
i said my job is to leave every
situation that i'm in
better than when i got there no matter
what it is
so you were playing a lot of roles
as inmate number one or bad guy number
three or whatever it might be
never number three okay bad guy number
one
number two i'll go for a number
so but there must have been a point
despite the fact that you're playing a
role that you kind of had played for
free throughout your life
there still must have been skill
acquisition that you needed to do at
some point like remembering lines
you know just drilling some of the
things to do with onset understanding
how to
interact with the camera and stuff like
that what were some of the challenges
that you had there
i i gotta say that the first five years
of my career really was like my training
you know i was really a glorified extra
i would get called on the set
as an as almost like an extra but i'm
sad so i'm making 320 a day
i'm standing there and the director
would inevitably say
daddy say something prisony and and they
don't present
they always wanted i'd take off my shirt
they wanted to see the dead
i'd get on and said treyo take off your
shirt i don't ever said that i don't
want to start that
and hey danny say something prisony
hey we'll kill all you sons of [ __ ]
oh my god
where did you study damn
[Laughter]
this one it was funny because there's
one director i was supposed to
kick in this door and uh
and they got four stunt people in there
and i'm supposed to rob this
this uh what do you call it
this poker game and i've robbed poker
games so
i kicked in the door i busted this one
guy in the mouth bang i hit this woman
boom
and then i've got this gun on this big
white guy
move move move i haven't shot a white
guy all day and
and cut my god danny
where did you study i said uh von's
safeway uh cvs
he didn't get it i robbed a couple of
pogo games
in fact the the
the the robbery that my uncle bought
from eddie bunker
in 62 was a poker game
been preparing preparing for 20 years or
something like that first
eddie says hey the first
half of your life was a character study
remember that
and so i mean i've just been
you know what i didn't even know that i
was being
typecast i didn't know what typecast was
i'm making 320 a day
what i care about typecast and the first
time i ever got interviewed was like
from some little girl fresh out of
interview school or something right
because
it means that danny aren't you afraid of
being typecast and i said
what do you mean well you're being
stereotyped as the
mean mexican guy with tattoos
i am the main mexican guy with tattoo
[ __ ]
what are you talking about i thought i
had a brilliant i thought i had a great
career going
and now she's gonna tell me i'm i'm a
typecaster young
and you gotta remember everybody is
typecast
tom cruise is typecast as the leading
guy
you know what i mean and it's like you
know i'm not going to do a whole lot of
babysitting
with with no that's a lie i
did a movie called the babysitter and it
was like
uh they called me cause they had this
real troubled kid and this kid glues my
motorcycle to the ground
just does everything then i end up
screaming running out of the house i
i forgot what movie it was so after
you've done this stuff you've been
extra in and then you must have had a
point at which you thought right this is
getting really serious now i'm having to
learn roles i'm having to do a little
bit more
when did you feel like you'd started to
level up
i i you know i i can remember lines i
i i heard somebody eddie bunker
my mentor he passed away if you ever
want to read a great
criminal novel read education of a felon
eddie bunk great really okay
and uh
uh it was funny eddie bunker said
that this old actor once said remember
your lines and don't bump into the
furniture
that was it and dennis hopper
who's a friend of i just dropped that
name dennis hopper said
trejo hey if the scene says
you drink water drink the water
don't act like you drink the water you
know what i mean
and i love him he was awesome operating
school and so he's
one of my best friends and i you know i
just learned along the way so when i got
a
speaking role my first real speaking
role
was with one of my heroes
walk talked exactly like my uncle
gilbert
a guy named charles bronson i did death
wish for her
and i grabbed him and i'm in a bar i
grabbed him hey don't i know you
and it was like the director load don't
i know you and pointed at him
he said that was cool and i don't even
know i did it
you know but it was what i would do
when i you know and so that was my style
do what i do you know you know and
he loved it anyway i got blown up by
charles bronson that was another one it
was a good one
you know i know uh it was it was a great
scene
what's one of you or what is some of
your favorite deaths given that you
the most killed man in hollywood what is
some of your favorite ones
there's no better death in hollywood and
it's a fact
when robert de niro i begged robert de
niro to kill me
in heat and it was funny because when we
did it
we're sitting there right before i went
into makeup we're both sitting there and
bob
bob said to me what do you think trail
i said you know i don't know what do you
think bob but
i said i play this and he said i think
you're already dead
and you know i i think you're already
dead
and what do you mean
well you know you just got enough in you
to
beg me to kill you you just paid me to
kill you
every breath the more and more you go
you know and
what do you think i see it the same way
bob
you just you hear it nail only exactly
what i was thinking
and so when we did it it was like you
see it they see we dying you see
every breath everything i say i die a
little more
and in the end i said don't leave me
like this home
don't leave me like this i
swear to god i have heard that a million
times
i have heard that from clerks in the
market
i i've heard that from grandma's pushing
their
car don't leave me like this homes
don't you know in markets gas state
everybody remembers that those lines and
thank you robert de niro big bob coming
in with the advice
wait i wanted to die you come on again i
want to die like
all right oh this is john wayne you know
that's that way i wanted to go out you
know
but god man it was like my daughter
can't watch that scene
she said no daddy i don't want to i
can't and she get up crying
simply because don't you that was your
life that's the way you were supposed to
end
and storms out you know so
yeah but bob told me to so listen to bob
right listen to bob
what was this story about you and kefa
sutherland didn't you help him out with
something wasn't he in some trouble
what was it he had hired some guy that
he thought was tough
you know what i mean because hot guys
hollywood like tough guys around them
but guys they can control they don't
like guys that
is like a security type thing yeah right
and so
and this guy ended up to be a total jerk
right
and then they couldn't get him off the
set because uh
uh i think keeper
promised him a sag card and said hey
what am i gonna get my sidecar that kind
of [ __ ] you know
when somebody says that you're supposed
to be quiet
about it you know and and uh and where
am i gonna get my line
and
so anyway they ended up escorting him
off the
escorting him off the uh set
and about two weeks later
uh i get a call on
george got a call my friend george perry
got a call
and uh we're down venice beach
and and uh george yeah yeah
okay all right kiefer what's up hey you
know what danny's that blimp
yeah he's right here he gives me the
phone and we're ben
i got a problem what's up
uh somebody threatened my my my my
family and
like what and somebody threatened his
family so he said
zoom and he told me and i said okay
don't worry about it i'll take care of
you no no
no wait then he got scared hey i'll take
care of it
no but wait i keep her you always take
care of it or not
yeah okay all right all right he was
panicked right but
but he didn't know what take care of a
man you know so so
do you think you were to get this guy
whacked yeah i think so even if he
didn't
i don't have to whack anybody but uh
this
this is a wacky union and so i i kind of
me and george just kind of like told
this guy hey
it's the last thing you want to do pal
you know
put a cherry bomb up your ass and light
it and
i think two days later his wife got
flowers and
i'm sorry and
i ran into keith this was 10 15 years
ago
i ran into kiefer probably five years
ago
and uh hey kevin what's up
hey hey trail oh wait hey i've been
meaning to call you
how are you doing you know because
i've helped a lot of people in hollywood
because a lot of them
think like i'm some kind of thug or
something and and and they
they i'll help them they'll either love
me
and and you know
be friends that call up on thanksgiving
and
come on over or be scared to death of me
yeah and just stay away from me and i
understand
because if if you're trying to be a man
if you're a man
and you're hollywood's got you thinking
you're really tough
you know and uh and you have to ask for
help
and this guy squashes whatever
problem you had then all of a sudden
you're either going to
take it as i'm weaker than him
or he's my friend you know
it depends on where your mind is you
know so
well i guess you've got those yes men
around people that you were talking
about before it can make that ego very
fragile right it builds them up it
builds them up it makes them feel
invincible
yeah right right you know what i don't
got no yes man
my assistant is a guy named mario
castillo
that i met in san quentin when i was
doing bloody and blood out
he was a resident he won't say he was an
inmate
i was a resident i was writing a room
and uh and if you look at him
if you look at the dictionary my two
best friends a guy named mario max
and if you look in the dictionary dude
cholo killer gangster it's got their
pictures
okay this is the boom let's just and
both
of them came up the same way i did
and uh you know it's like uh
we all have like the same respect for
each other
you know whether i work for you or not
you will respect me you know period and
and i do they respect me and i
uh it's funny the way god works i met
mario in 1991
and been my friend ever since
he was in quinton when he came out he
got clean and sobered and
uh i lived with him at max for a while
when i went through a divorce then when
i bought a house he came to live with me
because
he got sick and lost his job and i said
well worked for me
so uh became my assistant and
ended up saving my son's life
talk to me about how much fun it was to
do con air because that's a lot of big
guys big actors funny
that conair was so funny they got all
the wannabe tough guys
in uh in hollywood right put them all on
the same plane and
everything was a contest i mean if you
would spit somebody would spit farther
then
everybody started spitting and seeing a
push-up same thing
same thing oh all this this you know
there was a guy there
benny ukidis benny the jet
he was a five-time world kickboxing
champion
and uh he was uh uh oh
god what was his name conair
the cop that was the good cop uh
john my god i can't remember that
choose that john cusack right john
cusack yeah
and people don't know it john cusack is
bad i'm this guy he can he can he can
bend
uh uh a heavy bag with his foot you know
because
because benny eukitis was his sensei
and his sensei was also on them so every
lunch
when everybody started having these
contests
benny yukidus would come come on danny
get me and take me
what is it benny what why you keep
pulling me away you know he says
danny you grew up with my brother mando
and mando was as tough as benny you know
amanda was
in a dope feed and he said you're
exactly like my older brother
and my older brother was a bad sport
and didn't play well with others neither
do you
and he said and i know those guys
they're playing haha i beat you games
you know i don't play i mean i'll i'll
i'll
play fun with my kids and people but but
there's no winner there's no loser you
know because when you come to a winner
and a loser
uh there's people that don't want to be
losers
you know and that's not good that's
again like that
resentment you know that resentment
resentment
the way resentment works okay it's here
and say
wow that guy beat me spitting
oh he thinks he's tougher than me oh
he probably thinks i'm a punk oh wait a
minute if you are a pug
so no i don't you can't let that build
so i understood what benny was doing you
know
i love it man what about anchorman on
set how was that
hey funniest guy in the world i would
hate to be that guy
that uh uh oh god
come on dude i can't remember names
but anyway people would laugh when he
would walk into a room
the lead who was the leading anchorman
that wasn't um michael pharrell right
will pharaoh
okay he walks in people start laughing
he has this
aura of everybody laughed and so but
god he was funny you know what i mean
and i loved working with him well you've
got the alternative right he's the one
when everyone walks into a room and they
all laugh and you walk into a room and
everybody's terrified of you it will get
quiet
but you know what's funny you know in
blood and blood out
we did we were like we were our gang was
you know and it was patterned after the
mexican mafia but we didn't call it the
mexican mafia
we had gave them that respect the big
problem eddie did
was he didn't get it right and he called
it
okay so anyway i walk into a club and
there'll be like three guys you'd have
three guys from the mafia there
they'll be sitting there and girls will
be sitting and they
when i walk in they all stand up la
wanda
and because because it was a joke you
understand they understand
we didn't try to disrespect them we
didn't try to say that their leader got
raped
you know it's [ __ ] but and so it's
like i think you know so i've lived this
life that was mundo there's a guy
mundo who was one of the top dogs in the
mafia
he did a documentary and he said danny
trejo
is blessed because people on both sides
of the fence respect him
that's the biggest compliment anybody
could give me you know and
and uh and uh
i like that you know i like being
respected on both sides of the fence
i can walk into any prison in this
in the united states and and
and get love i i i can go to any
neighborhood
you know and hey
and that's beautiful that's that's like
what god's given me
danny trejo ladies and gentlemen trejo
my life of crime
redemption and hollywood will be linked
in the show notes below
you know what i also i got a record
label trails music
and we're getting ready to drop a single
and it's called
if you don't mind trish toledo and
coda the barber and i got i've got some
singers that are unbelievable i got i
got jasmine torres
diana gonzalez and tara new
so they're gonna we're gonna drop their
album pretty soon and it's gonna be
awesome and i just i just want to keep
doing it and if any of you are in
los angeles stop at my restaurant
trails tacos trails cantina hey call me
danny you're a sick guy man thank you so
much for coming on keep on rocking
brother
god bless you thank you very much for
tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy indeed
peace